this year is coming to a close and it's
like I'm just not happy unhappy lost and
damaged
that's how Tana mojo is summing up 2019
the 21 year old getting candid in a new
YouTube video all I can do is just at
this point be real about whatever is
going on and grow from it and learn from
it in front of everyone in a 40-minute
video titled the truth about everything
Tana admits her marriage to Jay Paul is
far from perfect I'm so unhappy with the
way my relationship with Jay looks in
the public eye and I've done so much
pretending that I don't care what I do
so it's my fault you know I loved Jake
so much I still do I did so much of
being like the cool girl and not caring
and because I wanted to do life with
this person and I wanted to see them
happy and thrive and I wanted to show
them that there are people that will
accept you for who you are and I think I
just put so much of myself into Jake
that I lost myself and that's not his
fault and I'm not blaming him for that
at all
it's just the reality I don't regret it
the YouTube personality even called her
highly publicized summer wedding hell
and a turning point in their
relationship everyone thought it was for
clout and fame and I think that made it
so much worse for me mentally because if
anything I would be so much smarter if
it was you know et was in Las Vegas with
a couple of just moments after they said
their ideas
but that was then and this is now the
second that Jake and I got married I
just feel like everything changed and
career-wise it was like this but
mentally it was like this here's a
wedding and here's mental state and
again I don't blame Jake I think that
the second he said I do to me he kind of
mentally was just like now what and I
think he mentally was also over it
I don't know and I don't blame him but
it left me like clinging you know like
trying to to make this work according to
Tana their relationship really took a
hit when they decided to make it an open
one
I feel like an open relationship to Jake
was him so be it ones have sex with like
a new every night which I am not blaming
him
I was so under enlighting everything
because I just wanted to make him happy
and letting it kill me you could only
let something kill you for so long until
it's like actually gonna kill you but
through all this Tana says she and Jake
are still together I always want to be
close with Jake no matter what I shared
one of the craziest times in my life
with this person and I feel like I
should have been far more transparent
with him and myself and the world and
the people around me but I just couldn't
Tanna ended the vid on a high note
saying she's ready to return to her most
authentic self it's something she told
TT at the streamys - the only thing I
want to leave behind in 2019 is anything
that's in offensive to be real I think
that it's very easy to get caught up in
the world of press and maintaining an
image 2020 for me is a really big year
of realness and authenticity
I am
[Music]